i read that you guys say oh hosting
saturday night live is the hardest gig
in show business
and i didn't understand that because you
guys had performed on it so many times
but it's that not knowing it's like oh
god the sketch isn't getting done it's
not funny i'm gonna go out and tank when
i came back to host
i was in 13 things and i was [ __ ] my
it was too hard it was too much like
friday night is when the host realizes
there's no way we're doing this tomorrow
oh yeah i remember cradling rosanna cat
you're fine i just don't think i can go
on
and i and i have had six years of
practice and i thought i can't even
handle it what if you're a real host and
you don't know anything going on and
you're used to being pampered on movies
doing a million retakes
and you just get out there it's like
this one your ups driver you have a
russian accent it's different at the end
it's on the cue cards go and they're
like what three two and you're live on
the air going what did you say i really
thought the last time i guest toasted i
had run myself so ragged all week trying
to in my mind fix or control the
sketches
i felt like joe frazier in manila i
didn't think i could get up off the
stool why does it have to stay the same
if they they got rid of some of that
live component put a couple of the
sketches in the can so to speak yeah so
it would be sort of like if you had two
if you had two takes it'd be better but
i think there's there's something fun in
the fact that it doesn't all work i i
believe it was inadvertently
one of the first reality shows so when
you have a football player
or a singer
try to come in in five days become a you
know live sketch player
it's it's it's entertaining i remember
jordan right behind the slats and i
could tell he was kind of nervous we're
about to go out it's live mike v michael
jordan who uh everyone was in awe
and i said just if you have to
just like christopher walken does just
look at the card and read it off the
card he would just look straight at the
card not look at you at all just beat
his line now
we're going to this to the zoo tomorrow
and i'm like what are you supposed to be
talking to me the concept that that
saturday night live is a reality show i
never looked at it that way but that's a
pretty interesting observation i had
billy eilish on uh just recently and she
like right after she did saturday night
live and you know what she said she had
violent [ __ ] and vomiting because of
the pressure of hosting saturday night
live she has to learn to open up about
her personal issues
what is she hiding from us i barfed the
second time
yeah is it true seriously that that that
there's a vomit bucket right next to the
the uh
entrance when you walk out that the
they should have one on stage for the
monologue you threw up when you hosted
saturday night live i'm sure you always
seem so you seem cool
really oh it's very stressful it's all
internal yeah
it was getting too much it was too many
sketches and i remember during
dress i started to feel shitty it was
really just nerves and david used to
pass out all we would hear is that david
passed out in the rethrow
eating but yeah david passed out you
know he's okay he was like david passed
out i would what do you mean because i
have low blood sugar no i'm not sure i'm
not this athlete that [ __ ] stands
before you today i was
a little more frail and fragile and i
couldn't uh eat [ __ ] but you're in there
for five hours it's a low ceiling
there's 60 people crammed in a room that
should have 20 people into it read
through is where i'd get a little
lightheaded so i bring food into it
like who the [ __ ] is this king lear
i'm like well we should eat it's five
hours